Trascrizione: Gianluca Finocchiaro
Revisore: Valentina Franzoni
Buongiorno a tutti.
Avete sentito i molti relatori che mi hanno preceduto
che hanno parlato
degli aspetti relativi al cervello
in termini di evoluzione, progressione
dal punto di vista di quella che è la potenza dei sistemi di calcolo,
in termini di capacità di simulare
il comportamento mediante i robot,
in termini di biomateriali
coi quali costruire biocircuiti
che possono essere messi direttamente
in comunicazione neurologica col cervello.
Abbiamo cercato, con questo progetto, "Human Brain",
di mettere tutto questo assieme
e di realizzare una piattaforma che possa far sì che
la progressione esponenziale di evoluzione
di quelle che sono le conoscenze che
hanno a che fare con lo studio del cervello
possa accelerare nel corso dei prossimi 5 anni.
Che cosa è Human Brain?
E' un progetto che è stato completamente finanziato
dalla Commissione Europea
sul quale abbiamo lavorato negli ultimi 4 anni
semplicemente per idearlo
e che si svolgerà nei prossimi 4 anni
da questo punto di vista, l'Europa è
molto più avanti rispetto agli Stati Uniti.
Solo recentemente
anche con una azione diretta da parte del Presidente Obama
gli Stati Uniti hanno deciso
di agire cominciando ad ideare un progetto
di Human Brain.
Questo progetto, a questo punto, è
in corso.
La prima fase è già in attività.
Nel corso dei prossimi 10 anni
ci sarà la mobilizzazione di oltre un miliardo di euro
per realizzare quello che è lo studio del cervello umano.
Un consorzio di
molte centinaia di laboratori in Europa,
di molte centinaia di istituzioni in Europa,
che mette anche in realizzazione la nostra conoscenza con gli Stati Uniti,
con il Giappone e con la Cina.
La prima cosa che è abbiamo realizzato
- questa è già stata realizzata -
è stata una piattaforma informatica.
Era assolutamente necessario mettere a disposizione
della comunità dei ricercatori
una piattaforma informatica che consentisse loro
di poter fare un certo numero di cose
che cercherò di dire rapidissimamente.
Come realizzare questa piattaforma informatica?
Mettendo i laboratori di simulazione
e di sviluppo software
in collegamento con quelli che sono
i quattro maggiori sistemi di supercalcolo presenti in Europa,
di cui uno è presente in Italia al CINECA
e che rappresenta il punto di riferimento
per quel che riguarda il Data Processing,
di tutti i dati collazionati in Europa
relativamente allo studio del cervello umano.
C'è un''altra cosa molto importante
che si è realizzata mediante questa piattaforma,
che è la collaborazione
di una comunità scientifica che mette assieme
anche dal punto di visto dell'interazione, dunque il linguaggio,
allo scopo di uno stesso obiettivo,
discipline molto diverse tra loro,
discipline che vanno dalla biologia
alla neurologia, alla fisica, alla chimica,
all'informatica, alle discipline di tipo ingegneristico,
ovviamente di tipo medico,
ma anche a competenze intellettuali come,
per esempio, l'etica
che, in qualche modo, proporrà quelli che sono
i limiti rispetto a tutta la sperimentazione che verrà svolta
e anche la filosofia.
Qual è il limite ultimo rispetto al quale
ci si può spingere nell'attività
di realizzare una piattaforma che ha lo scopo
di simulare il comportamento del cervello umano.
Il progetto si compone di 3 aree, che sono
sinergiche e complementari una all'altra.
Un'area relativa a quelle che sono le neuroscienze.
La metrica che viene utilizzata in quest'area
è quella dello spazio.
Nel senso che
noi conosciamo
come funzionano
- avete sentito anche nelle presentazioni precedenti -
quelli che sono i vari componenti
che costituiscono la struttura del cervello.
Siamo anche singolarmente in grado
di simularli e anche, per certi versi,
di realizzare in vitro i vari componenti.
Il punto è:
la complessità di questi componenti assieme
fanno sì che il nostro cervello
è in grado di avere delle funzioni di tipo cognitivo.
Inoltre, il nostro cervello è in grado
di avere delle funzioni legate al comportamento.
Come la struttura del cervello, a partire dai geni,
dalle proteine, dalle sinapsi, dagli assoni,
funziona assieme
facendoci comprendere e avendo un comportamento.
Questa cosa ancora non siamo in grado di capirla.
Ma da questo punto di vista
riteniamo che ci siano le condizioni per compiere
dei passi avanti importanti in questo senso.
La seconda cosa è la medicina.
La metrica e la scala che viene utilizzata
in questo ambito è quella del tempo.
C'è evidentemente una evoluzione,
che può anche comportare degli aspetti a carattere degenerativo
e comunque, in qualche modo, l'apprendimento,
la conoscenza, l'elaborazione ha a che fare
con l'evoluzione del tempo.
L'evoluzione del tempo, della raccolta di quelle che sono le informazioni
che in qualche modo sono ottenute
a partire da quelli che sono i dati diagnostici e da quelli che sono i dati sperimentali,
ci consentono di derivare quelle che sono
le singolarità del sistema cromosomico
che può essere in qualche modo agito
mediante quelle che sono delle azioni
dei principi attivi farmaceutici conosciuti.
Il punto è definire un profilo
considerando quello che è l'insieme dei dati disponibili,
che in qualche modo definisce quello che è il target
che possiamo andare ad intaccare
mediante un principio attivo e poi
simulare il comportamento del principio attivo,
che in qualche modo corregge una patologia
e a quel punto poter effettuare una terapia.
Dunque,
muovere un passo avanti importante nella direzione
della medicina personalizzata,
della possibilità di curare e di trattare,
a partire dalla conoscenza della struttura del cervello,
propagandola poi sulla struttura del corpo umano,
la possibilità di sviluppare una medicina che sia di tipo
personalizzato nei confronti del paziente.
Da ultimo,
il sistema - e qui la scala è quella dell'energia -
il sistema del cervello come sistema di elaborazione delle informazioni.
Il cervello umano è il sistema elaborazione delle informazioni
più complesso che noi conosciamo.
Peraltro, il sistema assolutamente più potente.
Il sistema che ha una assoluta complessità
dal punto di vista multitasking.
Funziona in modo multitasking assolutamente meraviglioso.
Noi siamo in grado di ricostruire le immagini che vediamo
e ricostruire le immagini è un'azione informatica molto pesante
- chi è esperto di videogiochi sa che
ottenere un rendering fotorealistico
di un personaggio di un videogioco
è molto oneroso dal punto vista computazionale -
ma il nostro cervello lo fa mentre parliamo,
mentre abbiamo un atteggiamento coordinato,
mentre pensiamo,
mentre memorizziamo informazioni.
Questo sistema è il sistema
più complesso per l'elaborazione delle informazioni,
anche il sistema più potente,
la stima è che la potenza di elaborazione del cervello umano
sia nell'ordine di exaFLOP di potenza.
Un exaFLOP è alcuni miliardi di miliardi
di operazioni al secondo
e il nostro cervello le esegue consumando l'energia
di una lampadina,
alcune centinaia di Watt.
In questo momento il sistema di calcolo
che abbiamo al CINECA Bologna ha una potenza
di 2 petaFLOP,
2 miliardi di miliardi di operazioni in virgola mobile al secondo
e consuma alcuni megawatt di energia elettrica.
Questa potenza è ottenuta sommando assieme
200.000 processori che funzionano assieme
sullo stesso problema, elaborandolo assieme in modo simultaneo e parallelo.
Il cervello umano ha una potenza
che ha 3 ordini di grandezza
e ha un consumo che è quello di alcune centinaia di Watt.
Riuscire in qualche modo
mediante attività di tipo neuromorphing
a simulare quello che è il comportamento
e la capacità di elaborazione del cervello umano,
è uno degli obiettivi al fine di riprodurre,
rispetto a quelli che sono i dispositivi di calcolo,
la stessa struttura e la stessa capacità
di elaborazione che ha il cervello umano.
Ci sono un certo numero di elementi molto complessi.
La rete di collegamento e di interconnessione del cervello umano è una rete dinamica,
che non siamo ancora in grado di ricostruire.
La prioritizzazione di quelle che sono le attività all'interno del cervello umano
ha una capacità di gestione che non siamo in grado di riprodurre,
ma da questo punto di vista esistono una serie di elementi
che ci fanno dire che è potenzialmente possibile realizzare
dispositivi che possono ottenere la stessa potenza.
D'altra parte, per effettuare la simulazione completa
del cervello umano, anche dal punto di vista
di quelle che sono le attività cognitive,
è necessario disporre di una potenza di calcolo
simile a quella del cervello umano.
Dunque lo sviluppo della piattaforma
è al tempo stesso funzionale allo sviluppo
della conoscenza del cervello.
Da questo punto di vista è indispensabile realizzare
una piattaforma tecnologica
- è quello che stiamo facendo dal punto di vista informatico -
che metta assieme i vari livelli,
quindi il livello neuro-scientifico, il livello neurologico, il livello delle applicazioni,
in un'unica piattaforma dove
le competenze lavorano - e sono in grado di collaborare - sullo stesso problema.
La prima cosa che dobbiamo risolvere,
che stiamo facendo,
è quella di applicare le tecniche di Big Data Analysis,
che in questo momento sono molto attive,
all'attività funzionale allo sviluppo del progetto Human Brain,
perché c'è un problema relativo a far sì
che noi si possa avere a disposizione
una potenza di calcolo in grado di poter gestire
la quantità di dati che vengono prodotti
per lo studio e la comprensione
del sistema del cervello umano.
D'altra parte, poter mettere a disposizione
in termini di potenza di calcolo
applicazioni che hanno a che fare
- questo è l'obbiettivo del progetto -
con 6 piattaforme informatiche
per gli aspetti di tipo neuro-informatico
per la simulazione complessiva del cervello,
per gli aspetti di tipo medico,
per gli aspetti di simulazione del comportamento del cervello
come fosse un calcolatore,
ma anche di tipo neuro-robotico - avete sentito la presentazione precedente -.
La sfida posta per la neuro-robotica
è che un robot che sia in grado di agire su un paziente,
per esempio voltarlo su un letto di ospedale
e dunque in grado di produrre una forza che sia nell'ordine di circa 100 Kg,
si acapace però di agire con quella che è la delicatezza
di un infermiere e dunque senza provocare danno al paziente.
Per far questo è assolutamente indispensabile
poter avere potenza di calcolo adeguata,
che possa essere implementata - embedded - in un sistema robotico,
in un umanoide robotico
e che possa da questo punto di vista svolgere le attività
per l'azione, per esempio, di cura in ospedale.
A che punto siamo in questo momento
per quel che riguarda l'attività in corso?
Dicevo prima che uno degli elementi cruciali
è quello della raccolta dei dati.
I dati sono quelli che vengono raccolti
presso gli ospedali, mediante strumenti del tipo
MRI, del tipo TAC, del tipo radiologico.
Ovviamente tutte le informazioni raccolte
da parte dei medici a diretto contatto coi pazienti,
ma è necessario andare oltre.
Da questo punto di vista, una delle cose che stiamo facendo
è scannerizzare mediante raggi laser
- quindi mediante una scannerizzazione non distruttiva -
quello che è un insieme di topi cavia.
Il cervello dei topi cavia - vivo -
è trattato in modo biochimico, in modo che
diventi trasparente - vedete quello che accade prima e dopo -
in realtà il topo cavia è vivo.
Da questo punto di vista mediante un dispositivo laser,
che è sviluppato presso il laboratorio di
spettroscopia non lineare
di Firenze - che è uno dei centri di eccellenza del progetto -
il topo cavia è sottoposto ad una scannerizzazione laser.
Si ottengono un certo numero di fette
della struttura del cervello del topo,
che però ha una risoluzione tale
- al di sotto della scala del micron -
che consente di poter osservare lo scintillio delle sinapsi
e la struttura degli assoni.
Questo consente, mediante tecniche di ricostruzione
dell'informazione, di tracciare
uno specifico assone
e una specifica connessione tra una sinapsi e un'altra,
relativamente ad un comportamento o ad una patologia
o una funzione del nostro cervello
- nella fattispecie del cervello del topo -.
In prospettiva ci sarà la scannerizzazione di un primate,
fino ad arrivare alla scannerizzazione dell'uomo.
Questa è la ricostruzione tridimensionale
completa di un cervello di un topo,
circa un petabyte di dati.
Un petabyte è la capacità che è in grado
di poter ospitare l'intera Libreria del Congresso degli Stati Uniti.
Quindi un cervello di un topo, alla risoluzione che abbiamo,
occupa una dimensione di questo tipo
ed è assolutamente indispensabile
collezionare molti casi, al fine di poter
progredire nelle tre direzioni che dicevo prima:
la direzione relativa alla neuroscienza,
quella della medicina personalizzata
e quella di poter disporre
di un sistema di calcolo in grado
di avere potenze nell'ordine di exaFLOP,
ma al tempo stesso essendo,
dal punto di vista energivoro, capaci
di poter funzionare con poche centinaia di Watt.
Tutto questo è Human Brain, in poche parole.
(Applausi)